so for example i'll give you one example
this ai feynman
project that we just published right so
we took the 100 most famous
or complicated equations from one of my
favorite
physics textbooks in fact the one that
got me into physics in the first place
the feynman lectures on physics and
so you have a formula you know maybe it
has
what goes into the formula is six
different
variables and then what comes out is one
so then you can make like a giant excel
spreadsheet with seven columns
you put in just random numbers for the
six columns for those six input
variables and then
you calculate with the formula the
seventh column the output so maybe it's
like the force equals
in the last column some function of the
other and now the task is okay
if i don't tell you what the formula was
can you figure that out from looking at
my spreadsheet i gave you yes
this problem is called symbolic
regression
if i tell you that the formula is what
we call a linear formula
so it's just that the output is
some sum of all the things input the
times some constants
that's the famous easy problem we can
solve we do it
all the time in science and engineering
but the general one if it's more
complicated functions with logarithms or
cosines or other math
it's a very very hard one and probably
impossible to do
fast in general just because the number
of formulas with
n symbols you know just grows
exponentially just like the number of
passwords you can make
grow dramatically with length so but
so we but we had this idea that if you
first have a neural network that can
actually approximate the formula you
just trained it
even if you don't understand how it
works that can be
a first step towards actually
understanding how it works
so that's what we do first
and then we study that neural network
now and
put in all sorts of other data that
wasn't in the original training data and
use that to discover simplifying
properties of the formula
and that lets us break it apart often
into many simpler pieces
in a kind of divide and conquer approach
that we so we were able to
solve all of those hundred formulas
discover them automatically
plus a whole bunch of other ones and
it's a
it's actually kind of humbling to see
that this code which
anyone who wants now is listening to
this can type pip
install ai fineman on the computer and
run it you know it can actually do
what johannes kepler spent four years
doing when he stared at mars data until
he's like funny eureka this is an
ellipse
yeah this will do it automatically for
you in one hour right
or max planck he was looking at at
how much radiation comes out from
different wavelengths from a hot object
and discovered the famous
blackbody formula this discovers it
automatically
i'm actually excited about
seeing if we can discover not just old
formulas again
but new formulas that no one has seen
before
and do you like this process of using
kind of a neural network to
find some basic insights and then
dissecting the neural network to then
gain
the final so that that's in that way
you've um forcing the explainability
issue
of you know really trying to analyze the
neural network
for the things it knows in order to come
up with the final
beautiful simple theory underlying the
whole
the initial the initial system that you
were looking at i love that
and and the reason i'm so optimistic
that it can be generalized
so much more is because that's exactly
what we
do as a human side this think of galileo
whom we mentioned right
i bet when he was a little kid if his
dad threw him an apple
he would catch it why because
he had a neural network in his brain
that he had trained to predict
the parabolic orbit of apples that are
thrown under gravity
if you throw a tennis ball to a dog it
also has this same ability
of deep learning to figure out how the
ball is going to move and catch it but
galileo
went one step further when he got older
he went back and was like wait a minute
i can write down a formula yes y equals
x squared a parabola
you know and he helped revolutionize
physics as we know it right so there was
a basic neural network in there
from childhood that captured like the
base
the experiences of observing different
kinds of trajectories
and then he was able to go back in with
another extra little
neural network and analyze all those
experiences and be like wait a minute
there's a deeper rule here exactly he
was able to distill out
in symbolic form what that complicated
black box neural network was doing
right not only did the formula he get he
got
ultimately become more accurate you know
and similarly this is how he
how newton got newton's laws which is
why elon can send rockets to
the space station now right so it's not
only more accurate
but it's also simpler much simpler and
it's so simple that we can actually
describe it to our friends and each
other right
we've talked about it just in the
context of physics now but
hey you know isn't this what we're doing
when we're talking to each other also
we go around with our neural networks
just like dogs and cats and
chipmunks and bluejays and we experience
things in the world
but then we humans do this additional
step on top of that where we then
distill out certain high-level
knowledge that we've extracted from this
in a way that we can communicate it
to each other in a symbolic form in
english
in this case right so if we can do it
and we believe that we are information
processing entities
then we should be able to make machine
learning that does it also
you